there are new drugs out there that can
prolong life for patients with fatal
diseases or even cure the previously
uncurable but they can cost upwards of a
hundred thousand dollars for each
treatment the textbook example is Gilly
adds soul Valdi sovaldi it can cure
hepatitis C and it costs a thousand
dollars a pill almost a hundred grand
for the full treatment but you will no
longer have hep c which is definitely a
good thing the subject of the latest
issue of Bloomberg Businessweek you can
pick it up tomorrow or read the story
today on Bloomberg com Paul Barrett is
with me now he wrote the story it is
fascinating it is thought provoking is
the kind of story that people will read
and then talk about with friends and
family surely what do you think about
this is it a new development that drugs
cause this much well this is a
development that's becoming more obvious
in the last couple of years we actually
had a decade where overall spending on
pharmaceuticals the growth of that
spending was kind of plateauing and
that's because the big blockbuster drugs
lipitor for example that millions of
people took we're coming off patent
going generic and therefore spending was
somewhat reduced meanwhile specialty
drugs drugs for cancer multiple
sclerosis now hepatitis C were coming on
the market and these drugs were being
set at very very high prices now as
these drugs come forward people are
realizing oh my god we have sort of a
new spending issue with pharmaceuticals
for these narrow diseases many of which
are life-threatening right and one of
the one of the interesting aspects of
this and I was listening to the story on
radios I drove in so I spent my entire
community thinking about it is on the
one hand the drug makers that are
charging this much seems like they're
being unfair they're holding people's
lives for ransom on the other hand how
much would you value a cure to an
incurable disease how much do you value
your life there's such obviously a huge
scale there right well what you have
here is it really a collision of visions
because the drug companies see it this
way they say yes this sounds like a lot
of money to put up up front
you put this money up you American
society and we will save you hundreds of
thousands of dollars in the out-years
you know we will avoid hospitalizations
surgeries in this case Hep C which
affects literate liver transplants so
pay the money now and be sensible and
then you won't have these payments out
into the out years now deliver a liver
transplant by the way is the thousands
of dollars not a million dollars and so
you could pay a 94 grand I think for one
of these treatments that's right get rid
of it in three months and on the other
hand point you you make is that you know
you and I aren't paying this out of
pocket people who have decent health
insurance don't pay it certainly don't
pocket the full cost that's exactly
right and the pushback that's beginning
to come doesn't so much come from
individuals there's some of that but the
significant pushback is actually coming
from companies like Express Scripts the
monster benefits management company that
operates on behalf of some 85 million
individuals it works for corporations
and insurance companies and Express
Scripts is basically saying in
connection with these Gilead drugs for
hep-c no we just won't reimburse for
those we will only go with drugs that
are less expensive leaving some
customers on malaria yeah if for sure in
the lurch either untreated or with
serious financial issues because of it a
fascinating story businessweek's Paul
Barrett my recommendation go out and
pick it up I like the paper version but
if you're if you want to read it right
away you can check it out on our website
right now at bloomberg com